let's talk about Kevin Hart for a second
we gotta talk about this guy because he
is always bragging to me I've work with
him a bunch of times great guy one of
the funniest people on the planet
obviously but he brags about his
basketball skills he brags and brags
about his basketball skills and you've
played basketball with him on several
occasions he suck he tells me he's great
you know the thing that made Kevin a
great comedian mm-hmm is he believed his
stuff he said basketball he believed so
well guess what here's what he said
about you recently on ESPN check it out
this is SportsCenter and I'm coming up
later and guess what I got thoughts on
draymond Green and for the record he
does not wash the back of his knees
that's true
and I beat him in a three-point
competition you don't believe me roll to
take why is it so hard to get the tape
straight face
[Applause]
three-point class after them right yes
you weren't a three-point contras them I
think we have a picture here of you guys
this is the outcome who's winning the
trophy here the trophy is bigger than he
had control a winner so easy got a good
three-point shot no no no you just not
having it
I mean he had a couple spots where he
shot well and I was shocked but no I
think you've made your point
you